let's go to the 7 1 8 area code caller
from 7 1 8 go ahead oh yes sorry David
can you hear me yeah we can hear you
fine
hi you know I'm just calling out just
during the stream but I had a question I
was just wondering how come I've been
watching you for a little while since
2016 I'm just wondering um why it
doesn't seem like you're that critical
of Russia Gator trip Russia you seem to
be very convinced and there hasn't been
really like obviously Bowlers
investigation isn't over but there
hasn't been any like you know you know
it's innocent until proven guilty
essentially right so I'm just saying
like why don't you have some people on
like Aaron Mateo or build any beast type
of people that have a lot of knowledge
of Russia Gate their crib you know the
critical of Russia gate like Glenn
Greenwald as well
why do I have them on your show and just
have a discussion with them because I
feel like it's good to be critical of
the intelligence agencies because they
did liason - you know 9/11 and I think
it's it's important to hold on a second
week can we explore this like a step at
a time maybe just because there's a lot
of a lot in there I know who Glenn
Greenwald is I have had him on the
program although it's been a while the
other people you mentioned I don't know
who they are you said that the we should
be skeptical of trusting the
intelligence agencies did you say
because they lied about 9/11 is that
what you said well what I mean is they
they essentially what they had their own
reasons for getting it into Iraq they
had their you know reasons and it wasn't
and it was very disingenuous reason
you're talking about a bush
administration right like so we're
talking about like a couple Devils so
first let me see if I can just break it
hold on hold on
okay we have time let's see if we can
break it down
I don't know if that's a toilet flushing
or where you're taking the phone call
but let me see if we can turn that down
a little bit we can understand each
other so first they said that that our
intelligence agencies lied to us about
9/11 is that do you stand by that or do
you mean that the case that the trumpet
that the Bush administration made for
Iraq was based on faulty intelligence
which which of the two did it I
essentially mean there was based on
faulty intelligence I don't know if we
saw the the you know the the meeting
where Robert Buller Oh on TV and
admitted and said that there were WMDs
that were in Iraq we literally lied on
the TV I didn't see now I mean certainly
there's there's no question that the
Bush administration decided to take week
and trumped-up intelligence and have
every you know Rumsfeld and : Powell and
condi rice and Cheney and the whole
slate of them justify a war in Iraq
despite Iraq not having had anything to
do with 9/11 so it sounds like on that
part we sort of are on the same page
right yes good so when now now when it
comes to the Russia investigation what
have I said that you believe is
inaccurate or what have I asserted that
is untrue well I would say that you can
keep referencing these from our meetings
there's nothing conclusive about that
speculation about which part is spec you
hold on a second which part is spec so
let's take a break let's let's really
drill down are you saying that it's
still not proven that the meeting
happened or do you agree that it
happened well I do you agree let's just
walk through it so we'll we'll get to
our point of disagreement don't don't
jump ahead do you agree that individuals
associated with the Trump campaign
including Paul Manafort and Jared
Kushner and Don junior were at the
meeting I agree that they were all at
the meeting good do you agree that a
Russian lawyer named Natalia vessel and
that's kiya who has now been indicted
for her connection
the Kremlin was at the meeting I agree
that she was yeah she was at the meeting
as well and do you believe that the
point of the meeting as has now been
admitted even by people on the Trump
side was the premise was to provide dirt
on Hillary to help Trump defeat Hillary
do you agree with that part I would say
that that that part I would I would say
that it's not 100 I wouldn't a hundred
percent agree with that okay so who is
arguing that that wasn't the case
because you have people on both sides I
mean even the Trump side now is saying
the meeting was under the pretense of
getting dirt on Hillary they're denying
that they got it but they're even
admitting that so who can you cite who
says that the meeting was not to get
dirt on Hillary well I would say that
he's obviously opposition research is
you know something that people do know
but that's not an answer what I was
saying was you said you're not sure if
you believe that the point of the
meeting was to get dirt on Hillary and I
said at this point everyone has admitted
that there's just a disagreement as to
whether they got the dirt so can you
cite anyone who is still denying that
that's what the meeting was for no I
can't find anyone that does that okay so
your your initial premise and bringing
up the Trump Tower meeting was that I'm
saying things that haven't been proven
what have I said that hasn't been proven
because so far you've agreed with me on
every point well what I'm saying is that
that that Trump's our meeting isn't it
it's like it's being cited there's some
like major thing that's going to lead to
some sort of an indictment on Donald
Trump and did I say
did I say Trump was going to get
indicted because of the Trump Tower
meeting you
basically insinuated that that that
particular thing is going to somehow
lead and down the path of being a piece
down the road so now so now you're
saying that I said Donald Trump will get
indicted because of the Trump Tower
meeting you're saying I said that is it
I want to understand no I'm not saying
that you
we said that I'm saying that you I in
directly indirectly said listen you're
insinuating it I I think that we've kind
of gone far enough and I think the the
audience sort of gets it I think next
time you got to be more prepared to
actually accuse me of having done
something I did and not end up agreeing
with me on every single point okay